hey everyone and welcome back to the
channel now you may be looking at me
today and saying to yourself huh Jordan
why don't you look like your normal pale
ghost of a self uh well actually as you
can see I look like a burnt sweet potato
instead I went to a baseball game this
past weekend that's right like a full
four days ago and uh did not apply sun
toan lotion or at least I didn't apply
enough of it so unfortunately now I look
red and uh you know you can make fun of
me in the comments and uh yeah let's go
ahead and do some systems design all
right let's go ahead and get into things
so today we're going to be covering a
bidding platform now at first I was
originally tempted to call this video
like eBay or something like that but to
tell you the truth uh it's a little bit
different the reason being that for
starters we're going to have slightly
different bidding rules than eBay has in
the sense that eBay you can like submit
a maximum bid and leave things at that
and number two is that this problem is
going to attempt to build for scale that
eBay realistically probably doesn't have
at the end of the day uh I've definitely
seen some popular auctions on eBay but I
don't think that any of them are getting
like a 100 bids within a second and uh
especially getting that type of
throughput the entire time so to be
honest uh if we were building eBay I
imagine they probably just use a
database everyone writes to a database
and then the database say some sort of
locking and then they use that to decide
who wins um that being said for our
purposes we're going to add a couple of
extra challenges to this and uh you know
make it into a far more complicated
problem than it needs to be in typical
JNL style uh so yeah let's get started
so our bidding platform it's going to be
very similar to eBay like I mentioned
but we're just going to imagine there's
a lot more scale uh than we might have
needed so Jordan's dirty gym socks these
are a hot commodity for sure as you can
see their current bid is $200 a lot of
people who want to pay for those 752
total bids uh Karina COV is the highest
bidder that makes sense she loves me and
it ends tomorrow at 4 p.m. and here's a
photo of my item as you can see they're
quite stinky that's why everyone wants
them so let's formalize some problem
requirements so number one is basically
that users are going to be able to bid
on certain items they going to be many
active bids or auctions open at a time
and users can place bids on them
obviously the highest bid at the end of
the auction period is going to be the
winner and auctions can basically have a
fixed end time so the auction gets
declared with some sort of fixed end
time or a variable end time that depends
on the time the last bid so maybe just
to you know stay fair if someone bids
with 1 second left it doesn't just end
right after that uh the time of the
ending of the auction now gets bumped
forward by 10 minutes or something based
on the time that bid was submitted cool
number three is that users who care
about this auction or maybe have the
page for the auction open in their
browser will actually get price updates
in real time number four is that we're
able to support a bunch of incoming bids
per second from different users for
popular items now this is the type of
scale that I'm truly not sure if eBay
realistically has anything like this and
even if they did it's it's possible that
we could handle them in a slightly
different way than normal that would
make our lives easier however ultimately
for this type of video I wanted to try
and take some inspiration from the stock
exchange video that we just did while it
was fresh in my head and uh you know
kind of use some of the things that we
learned there to apply it to this video
as
well
cool so let's first start by going over
the data models uh just because I was
thinking about this one I was using a
lot of terms that uh I think it would be
better if we explicitly defined so we've
got our bid right a bid has an ID we
have an ID for a specific auction we
have an ID for the user that submitted
the bid a price on the bid serverside
timestamp because we don't want to be
assigning them from clients otherwise
clients could mess with that it could
mess things up quite a bit and then we
also have a status so a bid in my
opinion could be accepted which means
it's now the current highest at the time
of being submitted or it can be rejected
meaning that it is too low at the time
of being submitted and even though we're
going to take it down as you having
submitted it sorry you just didn't bid
enough uh money and as a result we're
never going to count this thing cool
another thing to note is that we think
it'll be pretty important to basically
have all the bids for a given auction
available for auditing purposes uh
sometimes someone is supposed to pay for
an item and they back out and never do
and then you want to give it to the
second highest bidder so it's not enough
to just store that final state of the
auction and who won and the username uh
we probably want a trail of all bids
especially in case I don't know we ever
get investigated or something like that
it's important to have this type of
thing additionally uh this just means
that we probably want all of those bids
stored in some sort of Time series
database when this is all said and done
we can Shard that by our auction ID
because we just want to access all the
bids for one given auction ID at a time
probably sorted by their time stamp cool
another data model that we care about is
the auction state so this is pretty
simple but basically it's just going to
be some sort of auction ID we have the
current bid ID so the current winning
bid if I bid $100 and that's the highest
one that would be my ID the $100 price
and then the end time of the auction
because especially for variable Time
Auctions uh that end time will actually
switch based on the bid that's currently
winning cool so another thing to note is
that this is currently only 32 bytes if
we don't expand this data model it's not
a lot of storage and so it means that if
we wanted to do some bidding logic in
memory it wouldn't be too expensive of a
model to have we probably wouldn't have
to maintain that many servers even if we
had a billion auctions that would still
only be 32 GB of data that we had to
store and so yeah maybe we'd Bound by
something like networking speed instead
but at least from a storage perspective
you know perhaps we could get away with
just using a couple inmemory servers
here to do a bunch of our auction
logic so let's go into more of the
philosophy of the problem so basically
like I mentioned I'm going to try and
derive a lot of uh my inspiration for
this problem from the one that I did
about the exchange so the truth is I've
done a decent amount of research on
trying to build a pitting platform and I
didn't really find any great resources
what I did did find I didn't think was
particularly good and I want to try and
dig deep into some of the edge cases or
you know uh basically race conditions
that we can have here as we did in the
exchange video to see how we can learn
from that one in particular so kind of
the main thing to note is when we have a
bidding system like this you can have
two people who without knowing about one
another's bids meaning their concurrent
rights uh will actually submit a bid for
the same price and so in that case who
wins well if we were to use something
like a leer or a leader list database um
you know we could basically arbitrarily
choose one of those bids uh as a winner
and then go back to the user after a
little bit and say hey okay your bid is
actually on top now that is a possible
solution but one kind of premise that I
wanted to try and enforce throughout the
duration of this video uh is that when a
user submits the bid um they will know
synchronously whether it was accepted or
rejected now if I relax this uh premise
then this becomes a much easier problem
and I'll display that in the next step
or the next slide but when you actually
have the premise of saying okay whatever
the user does when they submit a b bid
they need to synchronously know uh
whether or not theirs went through this
makes things more challenging because
now every uh order basically every
operation or every bid has to be totally
ordered and in order to totally order
something we need to do that through
basically one single choke point now it
is true that we can provide a total
ordering of operations over multiple
different nodes if we were to use use
something like Lamport clocks but then
that leaves a lot of basically arbitrary
room where uh you know one node
basically takes precedence over another
when there are uh potentially two
concurrent rights and then that wouldn't
be fair per se so I guess you know it's
not the exchange right we don't really
care but if we do want to try and
maintain a fair bidding platform where
it's actually if I bid first and we bid
the same price I win then something like
a multi- leer or leaderless replication
setup isn't going to work for us we
should probably have something where all
of our rights are ordered by some single
leader and so that means that whenever
we have a single leader or a single
choke point to help us order all of our
bids to decide which ones are winning
and the actual order of operations that
happened we need to ensure that we're
getting a good amount of right
throughput otherwise we're going to be
in trouble so at least as far as I'm
aware one of the highest ways of
achieving high right through put uh and
ordering all the events and doing so is
by putting everything in Kafka so we can
do this and basically Al you know
because Kafka is effectively a log based
message broker uh everything is
inherently ordered by the log and the
sequence number in which it reaches kfka
so for example if we have user a and
user B over here and they're both
submitting conflicting bids one of them
is going to reach this kofka Q first and
as a result that one is going to be the
winner of the auction and then over here
you know we have got some additional
logic where at its own pace it can pull
from the kofka Q and determine if the
bid is accepted CED or rejected now the
nice thing about Kafka is it can achieve
really high write through put uh this is
as a result of you know we're writing
directly to a log so we have all
sequential rights and also Kafka uses
basically this kernel Bypass or zeroc
copy mechanism to ensure that when data
comes into the network card it doesn't
have to be copied into user space uh
which is like a a whole operating system
thing to be viewed um and so as a result
again it can achieve very high right
throughput which is great and then on
the logic side we can kind of read these
events as slowly as we want and
basically the order that they come in
from Kafka is how they're ordered so the
bad part of this at least is as far as I
can tell is that there's basically no
guarantee uh when a user is going to
hear back whether or not their bid was
accepted or rejected right it'll happen
eventually uh but eventually might not
be good enough they want to know within
the duration of their HTTP request
whether something was accepted or
rejected so again if I were to relax
this constraint and say Hey you know you
you'll just listen to some topic down
the line and hear about it that would
make this problem a lot easier because
then this Kafka solution becomes
feasible Kafka um you know would give us
fault tolerance and basically allow us
to ensure that once a message is in
there it's probably good to go and at
the end of the day uh then every single
uh consumer would basically listen to
the same topic and when a user submits a
bid maybe they have to wait 5 seconds
but eventually they would see that
they're winning I don't think that's a
good user experience and so I'm going to
try and do something with a synchronous
endpoint and that of course is going to
cause us a lot of complication hence the
length of this
video cool so again like I mentioned we
want bids that are synchronous right
when I submit a bid over here I want to
basically go to the server and hear
about it and so This Server that I'm
going to create I'm going to dub the bid
engine so the bid engine is going to be
very similar to the matching engine from
our exchange video but the gist is
really this is going to store that
auction State and it's going to accept
every incoming bid from any possible
source and tell you whether it's it's a
valid or an invalid one because the
price is either not high enough or maybe
it's out of the active time range of the
auction but the gist is we want this guy
to now be doing all of our bidding Logic
for us and it's now a central Choo so
since we're not buffering anything in
Kafka we need the throughput of this bid
engine to be very high so it's going to
have to be able to handle all of those
incoming requests and that means we're
also just going to have to be smart in
terms of how we deal with the
concurrency here right because if you
have multiple bids coming from multiple
sources at the same time you're probably
going to have to perform some locking on
the bid engine to keep everything
looking good now fortunately we
mentioned that the amount of state
that's actually required uh for an
auction is pretty small right it only
takes like 32 bytes to store the current
state of the auction which is really
just current bid price uh who's winning
and what time it ends so because of that
we can actually just keep this whole
thing in memory we started to discuss
that before it would not be a lot of
memory in order to keep the state of all
of the auctions there so again what
would be great is to keep this thing as
fast as possible not only do we keep all
this stuff in memory but ideally we
don't want to do any disc reads in the
critical path of deciding whether a bid
is valid or invalid and ideally we also
wouldn't want to do any network calls in
the critical path of deciding a bid is
valid or invalid and that is going to
allow us to uh basically achieve the
maximum throughput on our bidding engine
cool so basically as every single
request comes in we're just going to
have that request lock grab a lock on
the auction state check if the bid is
valid and then you know if it is that's
great return that to the user uh and if
it's not return that to user to but then
we can proceed so really we're just
locking that auction state for a second
checking if the price of the incoming
bid is sufficiently high and then moving
on cool so another thing is you know if
one particular bidding engine is getting
a ton of traffic because you know it's
responsible for hosting the bids of all
auctions we can just go ahead and
partition it out all that really matters
is that all the bids with the same
auction ID are being sent to the same
server or the same bidding engine so
that means that we can do some sort of
consistent hashing on the auction ID so
you're now starting to hear okay well
you know we've got this engine that's
trying to maintain really high
throughput and everything that it's
doing is completely in memory not only
are we not syncing things to disk but at
least up to this point we don't have any
replicas of it so how can we achieve
fall tolerance well the way that we
would typically achieve some amount of
fall tolerance in a situation like this
is adding a backup so we did something
very similar in our exchange video but
the general idea here is um you know if
we have a backup and we have a primary
bidding engine if we're sending our bids
from the user both to the primary and
the backup and another user is also
sending them to the primary and the
backup at the same time those two nodes
may actually disagree on the order of
the bids so one option to fix this is
you know to have some sort of middleman
that uses distributed consensus to order
all those rights or or you know to have
Kafka in there but we already mentioned
that we don't want to have Kafka as a
source for the bidding engine because
then everything becomes asynchronous for
doing stream processing and it's going
to be hard uh to give our user a
synchronous response back so using Kafka
in the middle is not a feasible answer
what we should do instead is the same
thing as the exchange video which is
going to be State machine replication
meaning the backup is going to basically
listen to the output from the primary so
let's go ahead and demonstrate that so
let's say I have a user right over here
I have another user right over here
they're both writing bids to some bid
Gateway and you can see they're arriving
at the primary bid engine over here the
primary bid engine might receive those
at the same time but because of the
Locking that we're going to use we're
going to establish a total ordering over
all the bids then once we do that we can
send those bids
synchronously over to our backup and so
that way the backup is always kept up to
date in fact if we really wanted to keep
things up to date to ensure that this
guy doesn't hear about the status of
their bid before uh that bid is
propagated to the backup we can actually
make sure that we put the bid on the
backup before a user actually hears back
from the B uh from the bidding engine or
the primary bidding engine
rather cool so that's actually not the
only component of this problem we also
want to talk about message delivery to
other interested parties right so
besides the backup uh bidding engine
that actually cares about the state of
the primary bidding engine we also have
this kind of audit database where we
want to see the history of all submitted
bids we also have other users that are
just looking at this auction and looking
at how the price is changing over time
and so rather than having our primary
bidding engine uh send this message to
all of those places at once uh because
that is going to put a significant
amount of load on it instead why don't
we actually just uh you know export
those bids to Kafka and then from there
everyone else who's interested in them
can handle them accordingly so we're
basically going to put these in Kafka so
that multiple consumers can go ahead and
read down the list and the nice thing
about Kafka is that it's fault tolerant
now of course depending on the
configuration of Kafka that you're using
uh you're going to have differing
degrees of fall tolerance you can do
some amount of synchronous replication
uh you can send the message to multiple
C Q's you can have Kafka do only
asynchronous replication and of course
all of this is going to impact your
right speeds as well as the fault
tolerance of all your messages so we can
discuss that a little bit more or at
least uh the pros and cons of some
replication configuration but you know
start to think about it if we want to
make sure that we're never losing a bid
from our primary matching engine well
that means that we also have to be able
to never lose it from Kafka uh because
we're first sending it to Kafka before
we tell a user the status of their bid
so what does our flow look like
now basically we've got our bid service
over here we've got a user that wants to
submit a bid we've got our bid engine so
that's going to be the primary so the
first thing that happens is a user
submits a bid says Hey for Jordan socks
I'm going to uh send $200 the bid
service is going to forward that over to
the bid engine the bid engine is then
going to say okay well before I tell
this guy whether or not his bid is now
the winner I have to make sure to put
this thing in Kafka so that everyone
else knows about it and in that sense
it's possible that this guy can go into
kafa and the bid engine could even go
down before this guy heares whether it
bid is valid or not at the end of the
day what that really means is that Kafka
is actually going to be the source of
truth of our system once a bid is
completely persisted in Kafka and
replicate and Fa tolerant then that
basically means that it is real right
this guy might not hear back on an HTTP
request but he will eventually hear back
from any of the downstream sources
because at the end of the day he's going
to be on that page too and he's still
going to be connected listening for
real-time updates to the price
eventually he will see that he is
actually the bidder uh but his HTTP
request might fail for whatever reason
so putting things in Kafka first
basically allows us to say okay everyone
else in the rest of the system whether
it's the audit consumers whether it's
our backup matching engine or our
bidding engine or whether it's just all
the servers that are then going to
forward price updates to all the clients
they're all going to agree on the
ordering because it has been decided
first by that primary bid engine But
ultimately Kafka is the source of Truth
cool so we published a Kafka before
telling the user if their bid was
accepted again this is going to prevent
the bid engine from failing before data
gets published to Kafka right our
alternative option is the bid engine you
know processes a bid says okay this is
valid let me go ahead and tell the user
that so that's nice however what could
then happen is it then fails once again
before anything gets into Kafka and now
that bid is not fall tolerant right so
it's not in the backup so then the bid
engine goes down this guy thinks he had
a successful bid it's not true the rest
of the system doesn't know about it and
now he's going to be very confused and
very angry and we're going to be in a
lot of trouble so that's another
situation that we do want to try and
avoid where possible is basically this
guy thinking that he submitted a
successful bid except no one else knows
about it and if no one else knows about
it and the primary engine goes down that
bid is effectively overridden right it
will get overwritten no one is aware
that that bid has ever existed cool so
of course we still have risk of bids
getting lost if Kafka goes down even
once this step three happens and that
bid is in Kafka it doesn't necessarily
mean that every single node in the
system is going to eventually be aware
of it it is possible that you know we
hit our single leader in Kafka and that
single leader goes goes down before it
can replicate things but again that's
why I say it depends on our replication
topology of Kafka that we're using maybe
instead of just publishing to one broker
we actually publish to two two Brokers
before we uh consider that operation
done and send uh status back to the user
but uh you know there are pros and cons
to all these approaches it's obviously
going to take a lot longer to process
bids if we publish to more places so
keep that in mind so a question is you
know if we're publishing tofka now how
can we actually keep our bid engine
throughput as high as possible because
now we're introducing an extra Network
call which needs to happen um in order
to return any data back to our client on
that synchronous API call so this is
where I'm going to try and get into some
pseudo code for the bid engine so
basically I'm going to present two
versions one of them is going to have
faster bids so faster bids basically
means we're going to return some data
back to our client a little bit faster
so in this case you know the first thing
that we're going to do is you know we
get some bid on our bid Engine with an
auction ID a bid and a price so we want
to get the auction State accordingly
that's just going to live in some
hashmap and we'll we'll get the the
reference to that object we're going to
grab a lock on it so now we're in the
critical path right in order to keep our
bidding engine throughput as high as
possible we want to do as minimum uh as
low an amount of work in this critical
piece of code as possible so all we're
really going to do is say okay well get
me the next sequence number uh of this
bid so maybe there have been 100 bids
this is clearly the 101st attempt then
we're going to see if our bid is
accepted which is basically if our price
on the bid is higher than the current
price on the auction and also if our
time is less than the end time of the
auction and then finally if our bid has
been accepted meaning the price was
higher then we can go ahead and
basically set the price of the auction
to equal the price of the bid so we've
updated our auction State we've read it
as much as we need to now we can exit
the critical section of our code it's
really just three operations and move on
with our life so our option here now is
what we can do is basically we can
upload our bid to
Kafka as we mentioned we would do bid
sequence number of it and then whether
or not it was accepted and then
basically we're just going to return
that accepted value to the user whether
or not it was a valid bid so a couple of
things uh for starters note that uh the
io piece is not actually in the critical
section
right and because the the iio to Kafka
is not in the critical section this
means that our bid engine can still
handle tons of bids at once because uh
you know all the contention is just in
this locking section over here and uh it
means that we could technically now
afford to do a more expensive type of uh
replication in kfco like a synchronous
replication that's going to help us
ensure that bids don't get lost once
they get published to Kafka however
there is a different race condition here
which is this guy because multiple bids
can be processed at the same time it's
possible that you know say our bid with
sequence number six might get to Kafka
before a bid with sequence number five
because we're not doing any locking to
ensure the ordering that we're
publishing to Kafka now the nice thing
about that is even though uh the
sequence number six bid might get to
Kafka before sequence number five we
still have sequence numbers in general
and so all of our Downstream consumers
can use those sequence numbers to make
sure that they're processing all the
messages in order if they see a sequence
number number X they just don't process
it until they first get the message for
x - one and so on however the problem is
basically let's say you know I send
sequence number six to Kafka and
sequence number five hasn't yet been
sent but then our bidding engine goes
down and five never gets sent the
problem now is I've returned accepted to
the user the user thinks that they sent
a valid bid and they did but uh no one
Downstream is going to process that
because they never saw the bid with
sequence number five and now they're
saying well shoot you know what I have
no clue what's actually going on there
uh I don't know if this is valid or not
so uh yeah there's basically going to be
a case of a lost bid so how can we avoid
that basically in this case what we
would want to do is ensure that when we
publish to Kafka we're publishing the
bids in their proper order so the
kafka's order is actually reflecting the
legitimate order that the bids were
processed in uh by the bidding engine so
this time everything's going to look
very similar except uh you know we have
some auction state right
here um and then what we're going to do
is say okay well eventually I know that
this thing is going to be uploaded to
Kafka this bid so when it happens just
return uh the accepted value that we're
uploading to Kafka back to our user so
we're basically registering a call back
function on when we eventually upload to
kfka cool then in the critical section
of the code which again we want to keep
as fast as possible we're doing the same
exact thing where we get the sequence
number of the bid we get whether it's
accept we update the current price of
the auction and then the last thing that
we're going to do is basically access
some Q some concurrent q and say hey I'm
going to call this current concurrent Q
to Kafka and at the end of it we're
going to put our bid the sequence number
of that bid and whether or not it was
accepted so now we have this internal
inmemory Q on our bidding engine that is
not necessarily going to be directly
uploaded to Kafka right now but it is
going to inq all of our bids in their
correct order then in the background we
can actually have another thread that
pulls from that queue every once in a
while and uploads to Kafka accordingly
so we do that on another thread in the
background then on our actual like um
you know handle bid function that we
call when an incoming bid happens we'll
basically wait hoping our Handler gets
called if it doesn't we're eventually
just going to throw an error and return
that to the user but the gist is what
we're now ensuring is that all bids are
going to be uploaded in their proper
order to Kafka and as a result of that
it is possible that say you know this
two Kafka uh piece never actually ends
up getting uploaded to Kafka because of
the fact that um because of the fact
that you know the bidding engine can go
down but even if the bidding engine does
go down uh we're only basically going to
return the value of accepted to the user
once it's been properly uploaded to
Kafka so we shouldn't have any errors in
this case uh where we tell a user like
hey you know you sent some sort of bid
uh but it's since been lost and we have
no clue what it is uh it is possible
again still this is not perfect because
Kafka can go down but uh depending on
the replication method that we use we
can get really really really close to
perfect here without using any sort of
distributed consensus which is very
nice cool uh one of the other pieces of
this puzzle is going to be uh the
consumers of bids so like I mentioned we
want to create some sort of audit log or
time series database of all the bids so
really you know we have this kofka q
that comes from our bidding engine that
takes in all the bids
uh we have some sort of consumer we're
going to sync to a Time series database
simple enough Shred by auction ID number
two is we also want to be communicating
the current price to our users so one
approach of doing this is to have these
user servers which again reading from
that same bids CQ we have some sort of
stateful consumer which is you know
going to be aggregating the auction
state so that it can see the highest
current price and then uh you know it'll
use server sent events to send these
over to a user
uh the users themselves will know which
server to connect to because we can have
a load balancer once again uh using some
sort of service Discovery or mapping
that tells us you know for a given
auction ID which server you should start
listening to for their service sent
events now it's worth noting that there
can be popular auctions right um you
know maybe this is less so the case in
eBay but in our fictional bidding
service it's possible that you know you
could have a million people who are
really interested in the price of a
given auction they just watching that
price go go up at a time so uh for
popular auctions not only are we going
to have a lot of people who want to get
the price updates but there are also
probably and this is going to be
correlated a lot of bids so the gist is
um you know we can have multiple servers
that are listening to this data or
consuming it for the bid data and
additionally for all of these servers to
kind of lessen the load on them they
don't actually need to know every single
bid that was submitted for a given
auction they just need to know the
current highest price for the auctions
they don't care about all the rejected
bids they only care about the accepted
ones so how can we do that well we have
our bid engine right here as we
discussed before that publishes to Kafka
we have our backup engine that listens
to those things I me perhaps the backup
engine or another consumer on the bids
kofka Q can basically look at all the
bids and only put the accepted ones in
the new top bid cofa q and then now we
have all of these user facing servers
that are listening to this kofka Q so so
it's going to be a significantly fewer
amount of updates if there are a ton of
erroneous bids coming to our popular
auction and then based on uh you know
some round robin load balancing scheme
we can connect all of our users to one
of them and have some sort of websocket
or service ENT events forwarding them
the
updates cool going to finally put a
little bit of thought into the actual
auction ending mechanism because I'm
sure someone will get mad at me
otherwise because I did say this as a
functional requirement so basically um
for the fixed Time Auctions obviously
we're going to have a fixed end time
stamp uh for the variable Time Auctions
basically as bids come in and are
accepted so this is saying in the
bidding engine uh we can update that
finishing time based on the time stamp
that is assigned to the bid cool so then
uh the gist is here uh the bid engine
will basically typo the bid engine will
basically occasionally check the time uh
you know that it is right now versus the
end auction time and if we we've crossed
it basically what we do is we can go
ahead and write to an auction database
with the winning bid ID so one thing to
note is uh if this winning bid ID is not
necessarily yet in Kafka what could then
happen is you know we put the winning
bid ID in some sort of database uh and
then our bidding engine goes down except
that bid is not fa tolerant just yet and
as a result uh now we basically put a
fake bid as the winning one in the
database so that would be bad so the
bidding engine should basically wait for
that particular bit ID to be uploaded to
Kafka AKA not present uh in the like two
upload queue that we have locally cool
and then as far as any derived data goes
because eventually we'll probably want
to show a user uh all the auctions that
they won uh basically take that auction
database uh do some sort of change data
capture on it put it in Kafka Shard that
by the user ID of the associated winning
bid and then you can you know do a bunch
of stuff from there but uh just as yeah
let's just use change data capture
that's really all I'm going to say for
now cuz I don't really want to get into
all the semantics of like how are we
going to notify a user that their bid
one um it it's not too hard as long as
we're doing something like this cool and
by using derived data then we don't have
to work uh worry about a bunch of uh
failure scenarios as well which is very
nice very nice uh let's see and then of
course once our winning bid is in the
auctions database um our server which
was holding the auction State can go
ahead and clean that up accordingly uh
because we no longer need it the auction
is finally
complete so I guess the last piece of
this puzzle is of course going to be uh
wrapping everything together as we've
covered thus far and so basically we're
going to go ahead and start from our
client as per usual so the client is
going to be able to do two things the
first is that it's going to be able to
submit a bid so when it does it hits
some random load balancer which round
Robbins it onto some bid Gateway so this
is just a server that's going to Route
requests over to our bid engine so the
bid engine like we mentioned is sharded
effectively per auction ID and is going
to handle all of the logic for
determining uh The Ordering of the
incoming bids so in order to keep
everything fault tolerant with our bid
engine we basically want to make sure to
materialize that bid in Kafka first
before returning any status back to the
client the reason being that ideally we
don't want it to be the case that the
client is always hearing oh hey you had
a successful bid and then it turns out
that the bid engine goes down and it
didn't actually so we do want to keep
the throughput on the bid engine as high
as humanly possible while also ensuring
that we have uh good correctness
guarantees for our system so again the
way that we do that is basically syncing
it to Kafka and using derived data one
example of derived data would be the
backup engine where the backup engine is
listening to the ordering that the
primary bid engine is uh is creating by
handling all the bid events one at a
time and then it's also connected to
zookeeper as is the primary so that in
the event the primary goes down we can
perform sail over over to the backup
engine and then every other system
including the bid gateways are aware
that they should now be reaching out to
the backup engine additionally another
piece of uh Hardware that's going to be
listening to the Kafka uh queue is going
to be our stream consumers so these are
going to do a couple of things for
starters they're going to sync all of
those bids to time series databases this
is so that we can audit them later or if
someone backs out of uh you know their
winning bid we can go to the next
highest guy another thing is that we
also basically in these extreme
consumers want to filter down the
incoming bids look at only the ones that
are valid so those that actually bumped
up the price of the auction and put
those into some second queue called the
auction State queue the reason we have
this queue is because it's a much more
filtered down version or condensed
version of the auction if there's a lot
of concurrency and that way we can have
all of our auction State servers
listening to that just cash the highest
price uh for a particular auction and
then as a result when a client wants to
get real-time updates for a given
auction they hit some sort of load
balancer the load balancer is going to
say okay well I can connect you to this
particular server over here because it
has the auction state of the auction you
care about or if perhaps it's a
particular pop particularly popular one
maybe both of these guys have that state
and then the load balancer besides uh
just figuring out that both of those
servers are valid does an additional
round robin component to all of this to
just randomly select one for you from
there you can then subscribe to server
sent events since this is just going to
be a oneway a realtime communication
from server to client and hopefully from
there we are good to go well guys let me
know if you enjoyed this video I
understand it's probably not the most
practical one and I imagine that in
practice someone like eBay is probably
just going server database establish a
lock um but I do think it's still a cool
system overall so uh let me know what
you think um I wasn't able to find any
great eBay uh systems design resources
online and so uh I hope to at least
slightly be a Trailblazer in this field
field but we'll have to see once I hear
from you guys anyways have a great week